what are your thoughts when you hear a  doctor making an argument to say  the mri now validates that you know  there's no such thing as being possessed  and needing a an exorcist what would you  say to that  i go back again from a faith perspective  in the new testament when jesus sent his  disciples out  he gave them authority over unclean  spirits but he also gave them power to  cure those who were sick so jesus  himself made a distinction between  ailments that were due to demonic causes  and ones that were just purely physical  in nature  and i think that that continues today so  yeah there are some that are certainly  due to uh physical maladies but i still  believe that there are some that are due  to demonic causes but again that would  be going and doing  that investigation trying to determine  how that came about